[Aplausos]
[Música]
tailandia es famosa por el turismo la
comida picante y algo que todos
utilizáis pero que no sabíais que viene
de aquí algo fundamental en la
fabricación de los ordenadores hablamos
de algo tan importante que hace que
tailandia aparezcan noticias como esta
los analistas advierten que las
inundaciones devastadoras en tailandia
están acabando con el suministro de
discos duros de los ordenadores
esta noticia es del año 2011 pero
creedme las cosas no han cambiado
tailandia sigue siendo uno de los
centros de producción de componentes
electrónicos a nivel mundial y fabrica
el 40% de los discos duros de todo el
mundo lo más probable es que el disco
duro que estéis utilizando ahora mismo
en vuestro ordenador
venga de este país y esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
por mucho que crezca tailandia se trata
de un país totalmente inestable desde
los años 30 tailandia ha tenido de media
un golpe de estado cada 4 años
[Música]
hablamos de un país totalmente
antidemocrático donde los derechos
humanos se consideran opcionales y donde
no existe la libertad de expresión para
que os hagáis una idea cualquier insulto
o caricatura a la monarquía tailandesa
te puede llevar a prisión
y por cierto es también uno de esos
países donde el rey puede tener
concubinas y ha dicho concubinas no
amantes lo digo por los que veáis el
vídeo desde españa en visual político
siempre os decimos que el sistema
político de un país es fundamental para
que pueda tener desarrollo económico y
por eso la pregunta de hoy es cómo es
posible que a un país con una política
tan inestable le vaya tan bien como ha
llegado tailandia a ser un centro de
producción industrial hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
en el país de los ciegos el tuerto es el
rey
todos conocemos ejemplos de teocracias
una teocracia es un sistema donde la
religión y la política están conectados
normalmente suele haber un rey o
presidente o primer ministro que toma
decisiones junto al líder religioso la
el ayatolá lo que sea bueno tailandia es
un caso donde el rey es considerado como
un dios literalmente el avatar del dios
rama en la tierra
[Música]
y ya sé lo que me vais a decir oye
fonseca pero no decías que este es un
país inestable cómo es posible que con
tanto golpe de estado la monarquía
tailandesa se haya mantenido durante
doscientos treinta y siete años pues lo
cierto es que desde 1932 se van sumando
doce golpes de estado exitosos y siete
fallidos ahora bien en todos los casos
hablamos de golpes de distintas
facciones del ejército luchando entre
otras pero respetando siempre la
monarquía eso sí por muchos golpes de
estado que hayan tenido siempre han
mantenido el mismo estilo de dictadura
militar en cualquier caso ya sabéis que
un poco de autoritarismo brutal nunca ha
sido un gran problema para recibir ayuda
del 'tío sam'
pensadlo bien en los años 60 y 70 a eeuu
necesitaba un aliado en la región y
mirad el mago
[Música]
por un lado tenemos a camboya que por
aquel entonces sufría una de las
dictaduras comunistas más salvajes de la
historia por el otro lado tenemos a la 2
que además de no tener salida al mar
también era comunista vietnam bueno
mejor no hablar de nam
indonesia también tenía montones de
problemas y birmania ha estado aislado
durante décadas y no quería aliarse con
nadie ni con estados unidos ni con la
unión soviética en otras palabras que
tailandia era básicamente la única
opción a todo esto hay que sumarle que
la monarquía tailandesa y sus dictaduras
militares eran fervientemente anti
comunistas así que vamos tailandia era
el aliado natural no sólo para eeuu sino
también para japón pero no sólo hablamos
de política
tailandia tiene una cosa única y
totalmente desconocida para el gran
público la divisa
el bat es la divisa tailandesa y es una
de las monedas más estables del mundo
hasta los años 70 tenía una tasa de
cambio fija con el dólar y todo esto
explica por qué los años 60 fueron tan
buenos para tailandia en 1967 ya
recibían más de 330 mil turistas al año
principalmente de países como japón
australia o estados unidos pero no sólo
eso como os decía eeuu decidió invertir
a lo grande en este país
así es como construyeron una señora
autopista de más de 500 kilómetros a
partir de ahí el gobierno tailandés pudo
empezar a construir su propia red de
comunicaciones red de comunicaciones que
todavía hoy sigue siendo una de las
mejores de la región pero no os
equivoquéis el principal socio de
tailandia no fue eeuu el gran amigo de
tailandia siempre ha sido japón veréis
durante los años 70 japón estaba
empezando a diseñar su agenda
internacional así es como surgió el
llamado paradigma de la grulla voladora
básicamente el gobierno de japón junto
al sector privado se puso a invertir en
los países del sur de asia y como
decíamos antes
tailandia era el mejor candidato para
poner tu dinero en aquellos años
así es como tailandia se convirtió en el
mexico de japón un lugar para poner
fábricas con mano de obra barata
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque ya me
imagino lo que estaréis pensando muchos
otro país pobre poniendo la alfombra
roja al capitalismo internacional verdad
pues lo cierto es que no por aquellos
años tailandia no estaba apostando por
el libro mercado ni muchísimo menos es
más en un país increíblemente
proteccionista para que os hagáis una
idea cosas como el alcohol los zapatos o
los coches tenían aranceles de hasta el
90 por ciento la mayor parte de los
precios estaban controlados y había un
montón de trabas burocráticas sin
embargo en los años 80 ocurrió algo que
cambió el destino de este país
[Música]
no
la capital de los discos duros los
primeros ordenadores personales salieron
al mercado en los años 70 pero el
auténtico boom del pc estalló en los 80
de repente todos los trabajadores de
oficina tenían su propio ordenador y
todo el mundo quería un ordenador para
la casa
[Música]
y cuáles serán los principales
fabricantes de ordenadores exacto eeuu y
japón
empresas como la americana atari o la
japonesa sharp dominaban el mercado en
sus inicios y pronto llegarían a apple y
muchas más
[Música]
desde el primer momento los ordenadores
han sido una industria muy competitiva y
eso significa que las empresas tenían
que optimizar los gastos tan pronto como
pudieran resulta que para fabricar
discos duros no hace falta tanta mano de
obra cualificada como para fabricar
microchips o otro tipo de componentes
así que de nuevo cuál era el mejor país
para fabricar discos duros un país que
estuviera cerca más o menos de uno de
los principales productores un país que
además ya tenía buena industria y buenas
infraestructuras pues si hablamos de
tailandia y eso explica que en el año
1973 sigue y technology una de las
principales empresas de discos duros
abrirá su primera fábrica en el país
pero no fue la única
[Música]
durante los años 80 tras varios golpes
de estado tailandia a cabo con muchos de
esos aranceles de los que hablábamos
antes liberalizaron buena parte de su
comercio internacional y todo esto
sirvió para que muchas otras empresas de
discos duros abrieran sus fábricas aquí
os acordáis del llamado efecto red pues
hemos hablado de esto mil veces aquí en
visual político en el momento en el cual
tenemos una masa crítica de empresas en
un sector instaladas en un sitio es
mucho más fácil que vengan muchas más
porque pues porque de repente empiezan a
tener universidades empresas
suministradoras y toda una cadena de
valor que hace que sea mucho más fácil y
barato producir discos duros en
tailandia que en otra parte del mundo
[Música]
por ejemplo en el año 1992 hitachi
empezó a operar en tailandia y ahora ya
tienen 40 subsidiarias y 16.000
empleados todo esto significa que cada
vez que compran componentes para los
discos duros lo hacen en conjunto y así
ahorran millones de dólares algo
parecido ocurre con seagate que ya tiene
más de 11.000 trabajadores en el país
producen 50 millones de discos duros
todos los años de hecho la mitad de los
discos duros de los ordenadores toshiba
están hechos en tailandia bueno si es
que en realidad el 40 por ciento de los
discos duros que se producen en todo el
mundo vienen de este país
hablamos de una industria que deja 12
mil millones de dólares al año en el
país y diréis esto es mucho es poco pues
hablamos del 26 por ciento de su pib
sólo los discos duros y parece que es
una industria que no va a decaer
sigue invertirá 470 millones de dólares
en tailandia en los próximos cinco años
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
es lo único bueno para tailandia al
tener una red de empresas tecnológicas
es mucho más fácil que otro tipo de
industria se consoliden es lo que ha
ocurrido con los automóviles en los años
sesenta tailandia ya tenía algunas
fábricas de coches ahora ya son el
principal productor de la región
mitsubishi exporta 4 millones de
vehículos desde tailandia para que os
hagáis una idea en el año 2014 las
empresas japonesas emplearon a 700.000
trabajadores tailandeses se trata del 1
por ciento de la población total sólo en
el año 2012 japón invirtió 11 mil
millones de dólares en tailandia para
que os hagáis una idea todo esto es el
dinero que hace falta para unos juegos
olímpicos
pero esperado un momento porque no todo
es tan bonito si es cierto tailandia
fabrica un montón de cosas muchas de las
cuales están en vuestra casa pero haber
tres capaces de decirme el nombre de una
empresa tailandesa venga a ver alguno
tú no busques en la wikipedia que te
esté viendo no os preocupéis que no pasa
nada es normal que no se os ocurra en
ningún nombre aunque haya muchos
productos con la etiqueta de made in
style and la mayoría de ellos están
diseñados por empresas estadounidenses o
japonesas y esto es un problema porque
si tailandia realmente quiere
convertirse en un país desarrollado
necesita sus propias empresas y sus
propias marcas aunque en realidad este
no es el peor de sus problemas ahora
mismo lo vamos a hallar la islandia en
la encrucijada recordáis todos esos
golpes de estado de los que os
hablábamos antes pues como podéis
imaginar no son una cosa del pasado sin
ir más lejos el último que han tenido es
de mayo del año 2014 en este momento una
junta militar se hizo con el poder y
aplicó una nueva dosis del autoritarismo
de siempre en este caso en el año 2017
escribieron una nueva constitución y
hasta convocar a un referéndum donde el
59 por ciento de la población votó a
favor de una muy bonito verdad podría
parecer incluso democrático y lo sería
si no fuera porque los militares
amenazaron
arrestaron a todos los críticos de la
constitución que pedían el voto por el
no o la abstención básicamente en este
país la constitución es un intento de la
junta de turno para intentar consolidar
su poder durante algo más de tiempo que
las juntas militares anteriores y lo
mismo pasa con las elecciones en marzo
de este año 2019 tailandia ha tenido
elecciones el problema es que los 250
senadores que ayudan a elegir el primer
ministro estaban elegidos a su vez por
la junta militar así que el resultado ha
sido tan sorprendente como el final de
una comedia romántica el general prayuth
chan ocha que es el que organizó el
golpe de estado ha salido elegido
etc
para ser justo en este caso tenemos que
reconocer que al menos han permitido
algo de oposición de hecho una de las
pocas fuerzas democráticas el partido
del futuro adelante ha conseguido un
flamante 18 por ciento del voto esto es
algo sorprendente en la historia de
tailandia pero el país sigue siendo
lejos de ser una democracia todavía
tiene leyes de blasfemia y el otro día
condenaron a 35 años de cárcel a un
señor que le dio por insultar al rey en
facebook normalmente este tipo de
regímenes tan arbitrarios asustarían a
los inversores y al gobierno lo sabe
sin embargo tailandia es un país con
suerte en la geopolítica y sus líderes
saben cómo aprovechar la situación
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tailandia ofrece un 50% de rebaja de
impuestos para los fabricantes que
abandonen china exacto la guerra
comercial entre china y eeuu tiene
muchas víctimas pero para algunos países
es una gran noticia
tailandia puede ser uno de ellos muchas
de estas empresas que se pueden marchar
de china buscarán otros países cercanos
con mano de obra similar
tailandia tiene la experiencia la
infraestructura y ahora además impuestos
bajos y de nuevo la economía está aún
fire otro sector que está funcionando
muy bien es el del turismo os acordáis
de esos 330 mil turistas que visitaron
el país en 1967 pues ahora tailandia
recibe más de 30 millones de turistas al
año
[Música]
si los discos duros son el 26 por ciento
del pib el turismo representa el 17 por
ciento y tampoco parece que esta
industria vaya a desaparecer pronto sin
embargo todavía tailandia sigue sin ser
un país rico todavía hoy en día sigue
siendo un centro de producción barata
para los países ricos o un parque de
atracciones para turistas no podemos
hablar de un auténtico milagro económico
como el de corea del sur japón o
singapur no tienen sus propias empresas
y si de verdad quieren tenerlas
necesitarán hacer muchos cambios en la
política porque si quieres que tus
ciudadanos inviertan en el país y
arriesguen dinero
necesitarás algo más de libertad y de
estabilidad política es de cajón de
madera de pino así que ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros queréis que tailandia
puede convertirse en una corea del sur
en mitad de la selva veremos como estos
países de oposición llegan a hacerse con
el poder y traen algún día a la
democracia al país o seguirá estando
todo como está
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre no olvidéis que
publicamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros a
visual política y darle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
ah